Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going to
explain an episode called “The Many Place” from
the anthology horror television series “Creeped
Out.” Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
The Blolesens family has come to North Queensland,
Australia to enjoy their summer vacation. They are
staying at a 5 star hotel called Ashgrove.
However, they are welcomed by heavy rainfall
because of the place’s tropical climate. As
the parents complain about the weather, the
receptionist tells them about all the different
activities they can do in the hotel without having
to go outdoors. The eldest daughter of the family,
Nita locks eyes with a teenage boy in the lobby.
They exchange numbers and decide to meet at the
swimming pool later. The youngest of the family,
Max runs inside the elevator and presses all the
buttons just for the fun of it. She is stopped by
the hotel’s boiler man. He has worked in the hotel
for several years and knows all its secrets. The
man warns Max against pressing all the buttons,
claiming that bad things happen to kids who do so.
He also mentions someone named Qinkin but before
he can elaborate, the hotel clerk approaches
them. She reminds him that the elevator is only
for guests and he isn’t allowed to use it.
The boiler man curses her and walks away,
leaving Max speechless after the encounter.
The clerk uses her keys to reset the buttons on
the elevator and brings the family to their room.
They are staying in a single room, hence the kids
fight about who gets to use the bathroom first.
Nita accidentally scrapes Max’s favorite black
sandals in the process. The sisters used to be
best friends but now that Nita is growing into
a teenager, they have grown apart. Max asks her
father if she will also grow up to become like
her sister. The father understands that she is
hurt by Nita’s behavior and consoles her. The
parents want some time free from the children so
they send them off to the hotel’s pool. Nita had
planned to meet the guy from earlier and doesn’t
want to take her siblings. But at her parents’
request, she reluctantly brings them along.
The middle child, Jett, loves to play video games.
He walks through the hallways while wearing a
Virtual reality headset and accidentally bumps
into a table, dropping a framed picture. He puts
it back upside down before entering the elevator
with his sisters. As usual, Max presses all the
buttons in the elevator, saying that the lights
look pretty. This time, they do not have a key to
reset it. All of a sudden, the elevator shakes
aggressively and starts moving. When it stops,
Nita tries to press other buttons but none of them
work. They blame Max for being careless and decide
to take the stairs. The hallways look different
to them but the kids do not think much of it.
Jett also notices that the floor feels cold,
in contrast to how it was some moments ago.
They go around the hallways looking for stairs
but cannot find any. The elevator that they came
through is lost and they have no way to return
to their parents. Even the rooms have no numbers
which Max thinks is weird. Nita tries calling
her parents but her phone has no signal.
They knock on one of the doors to ask for help and
see that it is already open. Inside the door lies
another hallway that is identical to the one they
are in right now. They check other doors and find
out that they are stuck in a maze-like place where
every door leads to a different identical hallway.
The younger siblings start to panic but Nita
calms them down. She claims that all they have
to do is find the elevator again and return
to their parents. Suddenly, they hear a loud
growl from behind a door. Max claims that
the noise is coming from Quinkin who the
boiler man warned her about. As the growling gets
louder, she starts to panic and hyperventilates.
Nita asks her to breathe and plays their
favorite bo-bo-ski game to calm her down.
But trouble arises when they hear a faint snarling
getting closer. On looking under a door, they see
a pair of monsters’ feet on the other side. They
screech in fear and run away through random doors,
getting further away from their original elevator
in the process. Max runs faster than the other
two and gets lost. Nita and Jatt try calling her
but she has run down several hallways and cannot
hear them. When Matt stops running, she calls for
her siblings and realizes that she has lost them.
While looking for her, Jett and Nita hear an
elevator door ding followed by melodic music. They
follow the sound and finally reach the elevator.
Nita doesn’t want to leave without Max but Jett
claims that if they inform their parents,
they will find her quicker. They get on the
elevator and Jett notices the red interior when he
clearly remembers it being a neutral color before.
The elevator shakes as it did earlier, making
them think that they will end up back in the
maze. However, this time, they reach back to their
floor in the hotel. When they pass the hallway,
we notice that the framed picture that was
upside down earlier is now in its correct
position. Nita uses the keys to open the door to
their room. However, they are met with a surprise
when they see two strangers inside. When asked
what they are doing there, the strangers claim
that they have been in the room for a week.
The kids then go to the reception and inquire
about their parents. The clerk who checked them
in only a few hours ago claims that no one of the
names are staying at the hotel. The boiler man
overhears their conversation and seems to know
the truth about the maze. Back in the hallways,
Max is trying to look for her siblings. She hears
a roar and curls up on the floor crying in fear.
Suddenly, someone runs towards her. On looking at
the person’s face, Max freezes in shock. Somewhere
else, Nita and Jett are confused out of their
minds. Nita googles her mother’s name and finds
out her number. The mother picks up the call from
her workplace in the other part of the world. When
Nita tries to explain what happened, she stops
her and asks her who she is. It turns out that
the mother is living an entirely different life
and has a boyfriend who is not their father.
She insists that she isn’t married and has no
kids, and cuts the phone call. The siblings are
left speechless at their mother’s indifference.
As they brainstorm ideas to get out of the
situation, the boiler man approaches them.
He asks them if they pressed all the buttons in
the elevator and calls them out for being idiots.
He also explains that the hallway they reach after
pressing the buttons is called the Many Place. It
is a cluster of pathways to alternate universes,
a place where all the realities meet. When the
kids look at him in confusion, he further explains
that their universe is one of many universes that
exist in space. Each universe gives birth to the
same people but with different realities. Like
their mother who is married and has children in
one reality, is a working woman with a boyfriend
in another. The Many Place looks like a maze
at first glance but the doors aren’t as random
as they seem. Each door leads them closer to an
elevator that is the path to an alternate reality.
There are a billion of them and hence, to find
the one they came from will need a lot of work.
He suggests they retrace their steps through
the doors and find the original elevator that
they came from. At last, he also warns them that
looking for the original elevator is not that easy
as he has never met someone who found
their way back after getting lost.
Jett looks outside the window and sees flying
cars that are considered usual in this reality.
The brother and sister go back to the
elevator when the boiler man stops them.
He adds that the Many Place was built as a
way to punish the humans who have committed
unfathomable crimes. The place they are going to
has a cruel creature who eats the lost people.
Hence, the children should be careful if they
want to safely reach their original elevator.
Following the encounter, they press all the
buttons and end up back in the Many Place.
After looking around for more than an hour, they
finally find another lift. However, on reaching
the hotel, they immediately find out that they are
not in their original reality. The place is filled
with smoke and the sound of missiles launching can
be heard from outside. It is clear that in this
reality, the world is at war. They return to the
Many place and start looking for another elevator.
After a few more hours they finally find another
one but it is filled with water, denoting that
the world is underwater in that reality.
On their third elevator ride, they reach an
abandoned hotel and lose hope of finding their
original reality. Nita breaks down crying,
realizing that she will never meet her parents
and her sister. When Jett tries to comfort her,
she tells him that they cannot go down billions
of different elevators. Jett, on the other hand,
asks her to get it together because she is
supposed to be an adult. With renewed motivation,
they collect things they might need to navigate
through the maze. They decide that finding Max
is more important than finding their original
reality because she might be scared and lonely.
Nita gets a horn, some pencils, and a stick
to fight the creature they had seen earlier.
Following that, they enter the Many place and
mark all the doors that they walk through.
They call Max using the horn and quickly
cross many hallways. But even after
hours of searching, they do not find her.
All of a sudden, they hear Max’s voice calling
them. She is just around the corner but she asks
them to not come near her. When the siblings
throw several questions at her, she asks them to
just trust her. She also urges them to keep their
eyes closed at all costs because she has someone
else with her who is helping her navigate. When
they are finally face to face, Max reveals that
the creature behind her is Quinkin, the monster
that Boiler had warned them about. Quinkin cannot
help but eat the eyes of people who look at him,
hence they should keep their eyes closed.
Apart from that, he is a gentle creature
who has lived in Many place his entire life.
He knows every corner of the place and wants
to help them get back to their original reality.
Max and Nita hug while still keeping their eyes
closed. They trust Quinkin and hold his hand.
After that, they slowly make their way to the
elevator and start it. As the doors close, they
open their eyes and get a glimpse of Quinkin’s
gruesome face. Thankfully, the doors shut before
he can attack and the kids are brought back to
their original reality. They see that the framed
picture is upside down and finally sigh of relief.
While walking back to the room, Nita asks Max how
she found out that they should close their eyes.
Max mentions the boiler man and says that he
is blind. Nita stops her and inquires what that
means. Then, she notices that Max isn't wearing
her favorite black sandals that she was wearing
when they first entered the elevator. Max also
mentions their grandmother and claims that she
is dead. Soon, Nita realizes that they picked up
Max from a different reality who was lost in the
maze as them. She is not the girl they grew
up with but is from a parallel universe.
When they reach their room, the group is beyond
surprised to see that the real Max is already
there. She is trying to explain everything
to her parents who clearly don't believe her.
That is until they get a look at their
daughter’s doppelganger and freeze in shock.
The movie ends as the real Max begs
her parents to keep the other Max
as their fourth daughter.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.